what up space fam goes in here from
anime operates finally time especially
with all the crazy stuff that's been
going on with him in the manga right now
for me to do an in-depth video on
Blackbeard quite possibly my favorite
antagonist in all of anime so make sure
to stay tuned for this one if you enjoy
these longer more in-depth one-piece
videos I want to keep them coming you
know what to do Channel parking with
them and smash that like button with no
mercy be a smashing pirate king rather
than passing Orochi make this video you
subscribe if you haven't already and hit
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates when
there's no new anime to watch or Manga
chapter to read Nikkei can let you be
the hero of your own anime an anime
where you can pick and choose your own
ultimate beautiful anime girl squad
command all your favorite Gunslinger
waifus in the immersive sci-fi shooter
RPG that is goddess of Victory Nikkei
available for mobile Link in the
description what I really like about
this game is the high art quality of the
characters the anime designs are awesome
and my favorite waifu would have to be
Scarlett love that she uses a blade in a
shooter game and her costume design
including that huge hat is great another
cool aspect of the game is that it gives
you a brand new perspective for a card
collecting game where you actually get
to enjoy the immersive shooting combat
rather than just getting the usual top
view effect this really makes it feel
like you're in the waifu populated Anime
World the list of Pros goes on like the
use of notable Japanese seiyu AKA voice
actresses the ability to choose from a
variety of gameplay in this
post-apocalyptic world including
roguelike puzzles and cooperation battle
there's even a vertical shooting mode
where you can easily operate the game
one-handed so you can play anywhere
anytime so what are you waiting for
click the link in the description now to
download Nikkei and start building your
own waifu Squad and be sure to let me
know which Gunslinger wipe was your
favorite download now and get 110 free
polls plus two popular SSR plus one
popular Sr for all the creators here's
your opportunity to shine Nikki is in
the middle of an in-game reward contest
named hashtag step forward Commander you
will have the opportunity to win 100
pulls look into the official Twitter and
step forward commanders download now and
check the cdknike love in the
description box and now without further
Ado let's jump into its spoilers and all
it is important to note here that Oda
the creator of One Piece has stated that
Blackbeard is his favorite historical
pirate as a result you can bet
Blackbeard is going to get very special
treatment in the story he already has
but that will continue so when I see
stuff in the comments like you're over
hyping Blackbeard I think if anything
most people are probably underestimating
him and his significance and I hope that
will be clear by the end of this video
yonko Blackbeard AKA Marshall D teach is
currently 40 years old a year older than
fellow Yoko Shanks and has the second
highest Bounty of any current Yoko at
3.996 billion he's only behind Shanks
who is slightly ahead at 4.0489 billion
put another way Shanks is only 52.9
million ahead and I have a feeling
Blackbeard's will surpass shanks's real
soon as we'll get into Blackbeard has
always been special even before he got
his op devil fruit Powers even back when
whitebeard's crew used to clash with
Roger's crew a young Blackbeard will
sing singled out kid buggy talks about
how they say Blackbeard never slept in
his life and he calls him a monster
ironically Shanks wasn't two phased by
him at this point even though he'd go on
to warn others like Whitebeard about how
dangerous Blackbeard is down the line
notably at some point more than 12 years
ago Blackbeard gave Shanks the three
scars he has over his eye and Shanks
emphasized that it wasn't because he was
careless rather Blackbeard was just that
impressive even before any devil fruit
powers and for anyone who says Shanks
has gotten way stronger since then I
raise you the very real possibility that
Blackbeard has also improved just as
much now we come to Blackbeard's insane
level of patience he refused the
position of second division commander of
the Whitebeard Pirates saying he did not
have that kind of ambition and people
bought it even though this dude is
arguably the most ambitious guy in the
entire Series so people that say
Blackbeard relies too much on devil
fruits are missing the fact that the
dude seems to have bested Shanks when he
gave him the scars and he was capable of
being a yaku commander before he ever
ate a fruit back to his patients the
only reason he joined the Whitebeard
Pirates is because he thought it was his
best chance of getting the dark dark
fruit and he stayed low-key until thatch
found the fruit and then he killed him
stole the fruit and left the crew to
start his own that tells us at least two
things that Blackbeard is crazy patient
and that the dark dark fruit must truly
be very special if someone would go
through all that just to get their hands
on it I also must say that Blackbeard
made quite the impression when he met
Luffy he said the age of pirate dreams
isn't over people's dreams don't ever
end it isn't easy to be great let them
laugh if you're aiming for the top you
don't always need your fist to show your
might end quote this is epic dialogue
and it could have very well come from
Luffy I like how Oda went out of his way
to actually give Blackbeard Luffy's
antagonists some admirable qualities
although there are important differences
I like how Oda also draws parallels
between these too now on to Blackbeard's
fight against Luffy's Big Brother Ace I
like how after auger and Burgess tried
to attack Ace Blackbeard tells him to
stop and that they aren't up to his
level yet I like that as the leader he
steps up to deal with the strong
opponent not even asking for help even
this early on Blackbeard tells Ace with
this meaning the power of the dark dark
fruit he's the strongest in the world
Blackbeard calls it the most dangerous
power in the history of all devil fruit
Powers no small statement considering
how many epic fruits are out there
Blackbeard goes on to explain that
darkness is gravity a Darkness so dense
it sucks in everything even light
infinite gravity this is Blackbeard just
showing off he tells Ace he's not going
to attack him yet and for him to just
watch as he uses his powers to suck in
the town he uses the move black hole and
the whole town sinks into the darkness
Blackbeard explains his dark gravity
compresses objects with infinite power
and crushes them infinite power that
sounds pretty awesome then he uses
Liberation and release says the
destroyed pieces of the town from his
Darkness it's nothing but scrap wood now
when Ace attacks Blackbeard however he's
surprised at the fact that an apparent
logia doesn't let Blackbeard avoid fire
attacks Blackbeard explains upset that
Darkness sucks in everything whether
it's punches blades bullets fire or
lightning his body absorbs pain and that
pain is actually Amplified in the
process but in exchange there's another
thing he can absorb he uses the move
black Vortex and explains that the
gravity of Darkness can pull in the
actual body of devil fruit users Ace is
sucked in until Blackbeard is holding
his shoulder furthermore now that
Blackbeard is holding him Ace can't use
his low gear Powers Blackbeard punches
Ace and he takes the full brunt of the
attack because he can just turn into
fire and avoid it Blackbeard further
explains that the other thing his
Darkness absorbs is the power of the
devil fruits and jumping forward into
the future my assumption is that this
fruit is also what allows him to extract
other people's fruits like he did with
Whitebeard but back to the fight and
Blackbeard brags that he has the power
to turn all fruit users back into
ordinary weak human beings finally Ace
decides to use his ultimate move flame
Emperor he summons what looks like the
sun Blackbeard just laughs saying the
Sun or the darkness only one of us will
win by the way this could also be
foreshadowing the eventual conflict
between Luffy and Blackbeard since Luffy
actually possesses the sun god fruit as
we find out later back to Ace and
Blackbeard though Asus fire clashes with
Blackbeard's darkness and we find out
later that Blackbeard won not only that
he succeeded in taking a living Ace
hostage Blackbeard gave ace to the Royal
government and then as a warlord
answered the call when the world
government gathered the seven Warlords
to help them fight Whitebeard all this
time Blackbeard was strategizing by
becoming a warlord he gained special
access to certain places and that
allowed him to break the deadliest level
6 prisoners out of inpel down and
recruit them similarly by handing over
ace to the world government he
guaranteed that Whitebeard would come
and so set the stage for eventually
stealing his Tremor Tremor fruit which
is considered to be the strongest
paramecia but let's get into more detail
with what actually happened at
marineford you gotta love how Blackbeard
brags to sengoku a legend in his own
right about how he only became a warlord
so that he could open the gates of
justice and infiltrate impel down he
rubs it in saying and I quote now that
it's done I don't need that title
anymore end quote when Whitebeard tries
to use his fruit Powers against
Blackbeard Blackbeard initially
nullifies them with his dark dark fruit
however then Whitebeard Cuts him with
his blade and then forms a quake bubble
around his head for maximum damage
Blackbeard then tells his crew to get
Whitebeard Whitebeard is already very
injured at this point but he's called a
monster because he just refuses to go
down Blackbeard's crew does in fact
attack together Whitebeard has enough
energy to Proclaim that the one piece
does exist before he dies standing it
should be noted that I'm referring to
the Manga version here since I believe
the anime extended the fight between
Blackbeard and Whitebeard and made the
wound that black received from
whitebeard's blade not as brutal thus in
the manga Blackbeard was actually more
impressive for being able to survive and
keep fighting after a more serious wound
keep in mind he took a brutal slash
attack and a point-blank range Quake
bubble from the strongest man in the
world and was able to keep laughing and
fighting very impressive then Blackbeard
proceeds to somehow steal the dead
whitebeard's devil fruit power but the
whole time they were covered up so we
didn't see how he actually did it but I
personally think it is tied to the dark
dark fruit and it's part of the reason
Blackbeard devoted his whole life to
find it it could even potentially be the
awakened power of the fruit but it's
just speculation at this point
Blackbeard then uses the dark dark fruit
and the Tremor Tremor fruit together to
people's shock not only does he have two
fruits which is supposed to be
impossible those two fruits are insanely
special one being considered the
strongest paramecia that can destroy the
world and the other being considered the
most dangerous fruit power in History
Blackbeard himself says that I quote
it's the gravity of darkness that turns
everything into nothingness and the
power of the earthquake that destroys
everything now I have it all I'm
Invincible I'm the greatest end quote
it's even more crazy that he's saying
all this while in the middle of such a
star-studded battlefield once again
Blackbeard is singled out for being
special Marco says it's true that normal
humans can't have two different devil
fruit Powers but he says teach isn't
normal his body is odd maybe that
explains it end quote Blackbeard Pro
claims that as of today his era begins
he says he feels he can control the
whole world and to start with he's gonna
sink Marine for it however tengoku has
had enough and in his Golden Buddha form
he attacks Blackbeard and his crew they
all seem pretty hurt by his shock wave
ultimately though as he was after
whitebeard's attack Blackbeard is okay
enough to even laugh he even dares
sengoku to try to protect the island
Blackbeard calls the power exhilarating
and causes a lot of insane tilting of
the battlefield but he comes to the
conclusion that he can't control it too
well yet even his own man tells him not
to overdo it or he'll take out the
ground under them as well Blackbeard is
insanely confident at this point calling
out Buddha sengoku and hero GARP asking
if they think they can stop him it's
crazy that all of this is happening
pre-time skip Blackbeard proclaims no
one can stop him he will destroy
everything he will swallow up everything
you gotta hand it to Blackbeard it
really seemed like he was ready to take
on everyone present until shank shows up
to put a stop to the war Shanks even
calls out teach asking him if he wants
to go but Blackbeard passes saying he
got what he wanted and that this is not
yet the time for him to fight Shanks so
this change in Blackbeard definitely
speaks to the power of Shanks at his
crew but it must be noted that
Blackbeard doesn't look scared he even
laughs they all got the same face here
after the war Blackbeard continues to
accumulate feet after feet in the new
world he beats fellow worst generation
pirate jewelry Bonnie and her crew he
ties her up and implies she's not strong
enough to make it in the New World world
he even says he doesn't need a weakling
like her on his crew but he'll take her
along if she agrees to be his woman she
of course refuses Blackbeard plans to
trade her to the Royal government for a
warship but the plans fall through they
find out that one ship is approaching
and that sakazuki is on it Blackbeard as
with Shanks runs off saying that he's
not ready to fight sakazuki yet which is
a bit strange to me since he was talking
big while sakazuki sengoku and GARP were
all on the battlefield at marineford but
there you have it his strategizing self
usually wins out and he doesn't feel
like it would be smart to take on Shanks
or sakazuki yet keep in mind this is all
pre-time skip compared to Luffy it's
still very impressive what Blackbeard
our protagonist's dark parallel
accomplished so far during the time skip
while the strats are training Blackbeard
continues to advance in the pirate World
a year after the Paramount War Marco and
the other remnants of the Whitebeard
Pirates Clash would Peach and his
Blackbeard pirates in what the world
calls The Grudge War it is quite a large
battle and and each side brings in
plenty of help in the end though Marco's
group is obliterated so it appears to
have been a very one-sided War this
really speaks to Blackbeard's power
because even without Whitebeard Marco
and the remaining Whitebeard Pirates and
allies should not have been weak at all
only after this major confrontation and
smashing Victory does Blackbeard join
the list of yonko he goes on with his
knowledge as a former Whitebeard Pirates
member to conquer former Whitebeard
territories to expand his crew into a
fleet and his old crew members become
Titanic captains while Blackbeard
himself becomes the Admiral who rules
over them all we also know that somehow
during the rocky Port incident Kobe
helped Blackbeard topple ochoku AKA Wang
ji a former member of the famous rocks
Pirates and that ultimately made
Blackbeard the boss of pirate island
teacher's crew is also focused on
chasing down powerful devil fruit users
since as we saw they have the power to
extract food powers from people after
ending them during the Zoho work we find
out that Blackbeard actually leveled the
Revolutionary Army's headquarters Luffy
thinks it might be because Sabo fought
with Burgess back in dressrosa it's a
pretty crazy side note in the story and
shows how Blackbeard doesn't even fear
Dragon the so-called worlds were as
criminal during chapter 903 luffius
proclaimed the fifth Emperor as the news
of what he did at Toto land spreads
Blackbeard just laughs while reading
this saying Luffy is not ready to be an
emperor yet the yet is telling though
and it almost seems like Blackbeard knew
he'd eventually earned that title as he
did after he defeated kaido we then get
to the wano arc former warlord gecko
Moria searches for Blackbeard on Pirate
Island he finds out that Blackbeard's
shiru now has absalom's clear clear
fruits meaning that Absalom is nothing
more than a corpse now Blackbeard then
invites Moria to join his crew he is
also excited about all the events
happening in the world like the straw
hats and others going to wano to battle
kaido and the revolutionaries fighting
with two Admirals at recovery he laughs
Overjoyed that the mighty battle for
Supremacy over the throne has begun he
even says No Quarter given meaning he's
going to show no pity or Mercy to his
enemies thus we potentially have Moria
joining Blackbeard's crew and there is
the possibility at least that they could
find kaido after his defeat at Luffy's
hands and finish him off morya wanted
revenge on kaido and a lot of people
speculated that Blackbeard wanted
kaido's mythical Zone fruit if they
finished off kaido Blackbeard can take
the fruit and morya can take the corpse
just speculation but it would definitely
make Blackbeard and morya very happy if
things turned out like this during
chapter 956 after the warlord system is
disbanded Blackbeard decides to set
sails saying if the Navy is only going
to take it he might as well claim the
prize we later find out that the prize
he had in mind was probably the meadow
metal no me AKA boas love love fruit
that has the power to use emotions of
lust or perversion to turn one into
stone Blackbeard was some crew members
comes to Amazon Lily saying that he's
come for the pirate empress and that he
won't let the Navy have her yonko
commanders Katarina Devon and Vasco shot
are with Him Blackbeard makes it clear
he doesn't care what Devon does to boa
as long as he can get those Powers as
submarines are waiting to get clearance
to engage Blackbeard Blackbeard sends a
Tremor attack their way simply saying
he's not here for them and implying he
doesn't want to waste time on such small
fry soon Blackbeard is confronted with a
pacifista it looks like a kid mihawk but
lunarian with silver hair brown skin and
black wings the pacifista attacks with a
sword and easily cuts a mountain like
mihawk did with the iceberg and Marine
Ford it definitely shocks Blackbeard but
Blackbeard seems to deal with it
nonetheless he blocks its attack with
armam and hockey and then uses the dark
dark fruits black hole attack we don't
see exactly what happens to the
pacifista but clearly Blackbeard got the
upper hand since we next see him holding
Ball by the neck as we know walk he's
holding her her powers are nullified at
this point we see that pirate Empress
boa has a bounty of 1.659 billion and
that blackbeards has gone up to 3.996
billion almost every Marine and
Blackbeard Pirate around including Vasco
and Devin has been turned to stone Kobe
is there watching helplessly he wants
Blackbeard to release her so she can
return the others back to normal but
Blackbeard doesn't trust her he's ready
to kill her and seemingly sacrifice
Vasco and Devin in the process but then
Rayleigh the dark King and Goldie Rogers
right-hand Man shows up it's actually
hilarious how he calls Blackbeard
whitebeard's Cabin Boy Rayleigh offers
to mediate and Defuse The Situation
Blackbeard decides to agree to the terms
and leaves however Rayleigh says that it
was only the particulars of the
situation which made it possible to save
boa since at his age he couldn't have
possibly won in a head-to-head fight
against Blackbeard now this statement is
huge praise for Blackbeard because if
anyone can see strength and is strong
himself even even if he's not at his
prime it's Rayleigh so it seemed like
finally Blackbeard didn't get his way
for once but even that's debatable yes
the combined forces of boa Kobe the
pacifistas and Rayleigh made him retreat
but his goal was also for the Navy not
to get their hands on boa's fruit and
now that she's in rayleigh's hands he
probably feels like the Navy won't get
it beyond that he didn't come away
empty-handed in fact he used the
opportunity to kidnap Captain Kobe the
hero of the rocky Port incident now he
has a very valuable hostage like when he
had A's and he even got his crew members
back but it doesn't stop there recently
we saw Blackbeard attacking lot as crew
we find out that his crew members gained
other powerful fruits like Doc Q with
the siksik fruit then auger with the
warp warp fruit Burgess with the strong
strong fruit that lets him lift a
mountain yes a mountain and stronger
with the horse horse fruit mythical
model Pegasus he knew that one of them
either lock hit or Luffy would come this
this way and he was prepared to fight
whoever came he wants to take all their
Road poneoglyphs and so we have this
fight now set up between Blackbeard and
law but Blackbeard is obviously the
heavy favorite though pun intended lost
crew hasn't shown itself to be very
useful so far while blackbeards is a
crew of monsters with Opie devil fruits
it's very likely that this will be just
another win to add to Blackbeard's list
of accomplishments and after he attacked
Bull and kidnap Kobe I feel like this
Victory here against someone with the
same Bounty as Luffy at 3 billion
berries will be more than enough to
propel his Bounty ahead of shanks's
bounty which is already really close to
Blackbeard's own so that was
Blackbeard's Journey so far until
recently at least but now I future gozan
will break in here to discuss the
updates for the latest chapter of the
one piece Story chapter
1064 because Blackbeard and his crew do
some big things in it the cover story of
this chapter revealed that it was in
fact kuzan who along with auger helped
to kidnap pudding and the two are
described as kuzan and auger of the
Blackbeard Pirates we knew that kuza was
associated with the Blackbeard Pirates
by some in some way but to just have it
confirmed here and to have him
introduced as kuzan of the Blackbeard
Pirates is a huge deal this means that
Blackbeard has someone that was seen at
least by some important people like
sengoku as being Fleet Admiral material
on his crew that should send chills down
all of our spines and it may even come
into play during the Blackbeard Pirates
and heart Pirates fight as kuzan may
freeze over the water in order to deal
with the sea Battle prowess of the hard
Pirates but more on that in a bit for
now let's jump into the fight between
Blackbeard and law as we're told that
it's a fight that shakes the World by
the narrator Blackbeard is using
stronger the Pegasus fruit user to fly
and head towards law La tells Chachi and
penguin to get in the sea and provide
cover Lai uses the move room amputates
to separate stronger's upper and lower
body and Blackbeard is surprised Eyes by
this saying no one told him his power
could do that and wonders if it's an
awakened technique interestingly enough
this seems pretty unprepared for a guy
who has been such a master planner up to
this point but I assume he's confident
in this win and we can't fault him if he
actually pulls it off Blackbeard uses
the Tremor Tremor fruit to launch a
quake attack and heart Pirates comment
on how the shock waves are too intense
as doc Q throws some apple bombs shot
she appears to use water to set them off
in midair so they don't hurt his crew
members clearly This Crew performs well
in water and Chachi even seems to be a
fish man he sounds confident as he says
it's a big mistake to underestimate us
when we grew up in the harsh cold Waters
of the North Blue you ain't got a chance
against us in a sea Battle all we gotta
do is sink your ship end quote what I
noticed is that this chapter has had the
heart Pirates looking good better than
we've ever seen them in fact but I feel
like that's only preparation for the
reversal keep in mind auger is here and
he was with kuzan who hasn't made an
appearance yet but that's not to say he
won't and if as mentioned he freezes the
water there can't really be a sea Battle
anymore Beppo warns Jean Bart about
auger sniping and Bart's steps in to
protect law he takes the shot with no
seeming problem leading auger to praise
him by saying he's some bodyguard law
jumps into using his Awakening groom
shock Willey since we know the Awakening
drains him quickly of stamina we know
he's actually in trouble and has to
finish this quick his shock Willy attack
hurts Blackbeard like it did big mom but
neither he nor auger look worried auger
simply says this is what happens when
you go in unprepared but then he asks
him if he wants to be warped back to the
ship Blackbeard although sweating says
don't be an idiot we finish what we
start and even Laughs Again Blackbeard
is arguably one of the best characters
at taking pain I mean he took attacks
from Whitebeard and sengoku at
marineford as we went over and seemed
fine when Shanks rolled up so although
he will show pain as usual on his face
it's very unlikely that law will be able
to keep him down Blackbeard finally
lands ready to fight when law tries to
imply that Blackbeard's officers having
devil fruits is a drawback because it's
like hauling around so many anchors due
to the fact that fruit users can't swim
Blackbeard responds that they are well
worth the trade-off and as I mentioned
kuzan's freezing powers would be a
complete Game Changer here if you showed
up but they may not even need him the
hard Pirates are trying to sink
Blackbeard's ship but his jailers are
confident that Blackbeard is the
strongest around and they have nothing
to worry about we see a clash between
Blackbeard and law and it looks a lot
like when Conker's hockey users clash
with black lines coming off from the
point of contact potentially it's just
Blackbeard's Quake Powers but as someone
who keeps saying that I think Blackbeard
has conquerors hockey it might be a sign
that he actually does if the hard
Pirates seem to be doing better up to
now this is when I think that things
change as the two seem equally matched
with their Clash Blackbeard begins to
use black Vortex the move that attracts
fruit users to him and nullifies them of
their powers he used it to beat ace and
boa so I think the hard Pirates will
start having much more problems now even
if Blackbeard doesn't finish it
immediately and that takes us up to the
latest chapter as of the making of this
video Chapter 1064 didn't change
anything about my hypothesis I do think
Blackbeard will win and the best law
could hope for is to escape but it's
understandable that Oda would let the
hard Pirates shine a bit before that
happens again keep in mind kuzlon hasn't
even made an appearance yet and law and
his crew already have their hands full
notably I also want to mention that
Blackbeard has a ship called the saber
of zebek showing that in one way or
another Blackbeard shares a connection
to the infamous pirate Captain who at
one point was the leader of many
legendary Pirates including Whitebeard
kaido and big mom to name just a few if
Luffy is taking the torch from Goldie
Roger symbolically then Blackbeard
appears to be taking the torch from
zebek in the past it took GARP and Roger
working together to beat The Rock's
Pirates so we'll see if Luffy will have
to team up with Kobe to overcome this
ever-growing threat too albeit if this
is gonna happen then Luffy or someone
else will have to free Kobe because he
is a hostage currently as far as we know
so a lot of people say Blackberry is
overrated but I hope this video shows
that that's definitely not the case
Janko Shanks a guy usually so Carefree a
guy who is practically flexed every time
he appeared on screen and has never even
needed to show his true power clearly
Fierce Blackbeard it appears Blackbeard
bested him before when he gave him those
scars and it was not because Shanks was
careless Blackbeard was just that good
even before he got his insanely
overpowered devil fruit Powers he
worried Shang so much that Shanks felt
the need to warn the strongest man in
the world not to go after him Shanks was
right of course and Blackbeard ended up
with whitebeard's fruit power and kept
getting stronger and stronger until we
reached this point where he's just about
to surpass shanks's Bounty if you ask me
he was furthermore raised by Rayleigh
the pirate King's right-hand man and the
guy who trained Luffy over the time skip
Rayleigh an absolute Legend revealed
that he couldn't beat Blackbeard anymore
that's a huge comment even if he's not
in his prime anymore and it's a comment
that should not be overlooked Blackbeard
is confident he can beat Luffy as he
said himself Luffy was one of the people
he knew might come the way law
eventually came and the story has
progressed like that where Blackbeard
was always ahead of Luffy think about
how much he accomplished a marine for it
while Luffy couldn't even protect Ace so
even though Luffy got stronger and even
just be kaido we can't assume Blackbeard
didn't get stronger too and on top of
that we know how Shonen work and it's
unlikely Blackbeard Luffy's big
antagonist that he's yet to fight is
going to be weaker than kaido was and
opponent Luffy has already beaten it is
my guess that when they start their
final epic fight Blackbeard will be
stronger and during the course of the
fight Luffy will have to grow to the
point where he can finally surpass him
however before that I do believe that
Blackbeard will in some way demonstrate
that he surpassed Shanks he may even
defeat Shanks in battle so as to Hype up
the final confrontation between the Sun
and darkness all the more I've also
matched the connection between Shanks
and the God of War tier in my hour-long
Shanks is stronger than you think video
and that's relevant for this video as
well because that Norse myth also seems
to set up Shanks in Blackbeard as
enemies faded to clash not only has
Blackbeard hinted at this when he said
at the Paramount war that it's not yet
time for them to fight but tears fade
during Ragnarok was to be slain by the
wolf Garber who is called the greatest
monster remember that Blackbeard will
similarly referred to as a monster by
buggy garmer has also been connected to
the Greek mythological dog Cerberus
before Cerberus is often portrayed as a
three-headed dog which makes us think of
shanks's greatest enemy in one piece
Blackbeard the yonko with three skulls
on his pirate flag in this line of
thinking also suggests that Blackbeard
could have at least three devil fruits
one free head but anyways this final
battle between Shanks and Blackbeard has
long been foreshadowed and built up
Shakespeare's Blackbeard more than any
other as he warned Whitebeard and only
the scars Blackbeard gave him still her
Shanks even though he clashed with so
many other strong opponents thus I do
believe that Shanks will eventually fall
to Blackbeard whether he's killed like
the Norse god of war or is simply
defeated remains to be seen so that's
why everyone including the current yonko
with the highest Bounty Shanks Fierce
Blackbeard the dude seems fated to
become the strongest pirate if he's not
already in his patience and ability to
know who he should fight and when makes
him all the more scary he can't be
pinned down like Luffy's power and
influence is growing all the time and
that's what makes him such a scary and
at the same time great antagonist in one
piece and one of the craziest things to
me is still the fact that kuzan the
former Admiral and almost Fleet Admiral
is even working for Blackbeard now just
the idea that someone who could fight
sakazuki for 10 days and who is strong
enough to be a fleet Admiral would work
work under Blackbeard Hypes up
Blackbeard to no end it's also pretty
fitting for someone like Blackbeard who
like zebek wants to be king of the world
so now channeled pirate king within and
smash that like button if you enjoyed
this video if we can hit 5 000 likes on
this one I'll do a similar long video
for another character like Goldie Roger
for instance make this the video you
subscribe if you haven't already and hit
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates while you
wait for the next chapter or video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on the yonko Warlords an hour-long video
about Shanks and much more link to that
is in the description and on screen
right now and until next time see us
Space Cowboys